and then how do you in times of
uncertainty like we have right now right
earlier you talked about unknowns in the
future being the biggest unknown but
right now it's less about the future
unknown I think there's just a lot of
uncertainty which seems tangentially
related but but but almost worse how do
you talk to people about processing
information making sure if they have the
sound decision-making and then really
operating in a time where every decision
every action feels like it just has more
weight on it and there's a lot of
uncertainty in the air so the first
skill is just to be able to sit with it
is literally just to be able to tolerate
the uncertainty and go you know what I
can't meet what I think is a good
prediction or a good bet that's a skill
and a lot of people can't do that and I
think we're seeing like a lot of
decisions being made that are about us
waging the fact that that's an
uncomfortable place to be because when
you make a decision it feels a little
bit more certain just because you
decided even though you know the
California schools are my example of
that wait a week or so ago they said you
know no classes in the fall like on May
whatever one has to keep they didn't
need to make that decision but it made
them feel like more certain so there's a
skill of just being tolerated then
there's like making lists okay what what
do we know what's not inevitable
what can we maybe find out a little bit
more about and when did we really have
to make this decision like I know
someone you know startup company New
York thinks that they heard me talk
about like do I really have to make the
decision for what period of time their
lease is coming up I don't know I think
it's in the fall and the staff has all
been like are we going back arguing sign
of weeks the CEO has been like I don't
know not making that decision today we
don't have to make that decision today
but again how do you
do that you're just you have to be able
to tolerate the fact that you don't know
so there tends to be a bias for action
then I think that bias for action is
somewhat misguided now there's this idea
that people default to inaction I think
it's generally the other way around you
don't want to do something to make the
feelings go away just live with the
feelings you'll figure out a better
thing to do as time unfolds I've always
thought of it and whether it's right or
not as people want to feel in control
right and the way they feel in control
is that you do something I can impact
the situation whether it ends up being
good impact or not and one of my
favorite studies
I keep Murph it was Vanguard or fidelity
you know somebody did a analysis on the
best-performing accounts they had and in
the retail sector it was people who had
forgotten their passwords or died yeah
look is probably wasn't a bad strategy
I guess the aspect of kind of
uncertainty and especially right now I
think is a time where people are
thinking about this is fear
right so uncertainty to me feels like I
gave you plot a scale it's not on the
easy end but it's not on the most
extreme
of the hard decision making it's just
uncomfortable aspect you know fear is
like the extreme end of I am literally
scared I'm going to lose money
make a bad decision you know whatever it
ends up being how do you talk to
especially large asset managers right
where that fear if it ends up becoming
reality they don't just lose 20 bucks
right we're talking you know millions or
tens of millions of dollars other
people's money how do you talk to them
about fear and kind of walk them through
when they are fearful to be able to
answer is what am I feeling and why am I
feeling so I try to get them to put that
fear into words and I often try to try
to get them to really get to why it is
so either I've asked for more in the
past two months then I asked one time
what's the worst that can happen so yeah
this is something I think is a little
bit different about our method like
we're going right at the fear and almost
universally the worst that can happen
actually if the person really tries to
answer that question he's some version
of catastrophe you know they go through
losing money losing investors losing
employees losing their fun losing their
spouse their life is disaster or this is
a long time ago but I once had someone
tell me and my kids are drug dealers and
prostitutes like it's sort of a natural
human tendency to down deeper there near
honest attacks tricky scenario and you
don't realize it because you're not
going down the rabbit hole because
you're told not to drive away but it's
that catastrophe prediction that's
linked to spirits that's influencing
here and what happens is when you look
at it go away well that's probably not
likely to happen but even if it is gonna
happen there's like a hundred steps
between here and there that I can you
know invert that reality so I that's a
long-winded way of saying I get all the
fears out in the open and then we look
at them which ones are real and which
ones are exaggerated which ones are
relevant to whatever decisions you gotta
make right now in which ones are
irrelevant you know meaning they're
about something else or they can be put
off or so it's like sorting through the
spaghetti bowl of beer
it's using this research that sense
emotion differentiation from emotion
granularity meaning like fear panic
nervousness nervousness worry doubt like
all the different intensities being able
to sort through that should you act on
it less ironic being able to sort
through it gives you a wider range of
choices and stop you from impulsively
acting on it just to feel better or to
feel in control yeah it's really
interesting again it's around awareness
right kind of having an understanding of
what's happening makes it less powerful
to some degree like the forces being
active on you the the age-old question I
know somebody listening to this will ask
it is are the absolute best in the world
ever scared or are emotional control to
to avoid fear and maybe just sit with
the uncertainty or does it ever get to
that point maybe there's somebody out
there that's you know less even than the
next one but it's actually any it's a
strength to be able to admit fear like
and also in its pure form it's a source
of information so I think the very best
in the world understand it that way that
you know some fears are are warning you
of something you should be afraid of
some are irrelevant the skill is to know
the difference